content editor and editor
[Music]
Kaelin the podcast is started how do we
even podcast anymore
hey alright guys welcome to the Evan and
Caitlyn podcast the podcast where
Caitlyn is ready yeah yeah all right
guys today we're gonna be talking about
making how did we start making how can
you start making what are the common
excuses that people have for not making
right now and how to get over them we
asked our patrons to send in questions
about about getting started with making
and roadblocks and things like that so
we'll answer some of those and Caitlyn
has a very exciting challenge game for
me it's Evan verse Pinterest yes
Pinterest trends and stuff like like
what what is more popular than what then
stop I have I'm gonna be horrible yeah
you're gonna be yeah stay stay tuned for
the games there's gonna be a
slaughterhouse I think you're gonna do
better than you expect oh thank you
thank you for the vote of confidence
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all right so let's start with how we
started making I think we started making
generally to save money because of this
one yeah me too me too I liked making I
wanted to make but I think that you are
the impetus behind the push yeah which
is funny because it slowly turned from
the desire to save money to like a
spending way more on tools and in some
cases more on tools and materials making
the things than we do saving money but
it's really we are still saving money if
we wanted this desk right here the one
we're sitting at yeah but with that with
the resin river and LED lights and the
cable storage that would have been very
expensive we saved money that's not
making this by spending the money it
gets a little bit funky yeah it started
out very simple like
I think the very first inspiration for
our very first project was we were at a
wedding expo for a friend's wedding
planning and Kaelin saw these love
letters yeah I think we've told the
story on the podcast before never mind
these big like two foot tall marquee
letters and we wanted to make them
because renting them or buying them was
very expensive so we made them for like
$80 use for letters and and we have we
have we had all of the excuses that
everyone might have we had no reason to
think we could do it yeah neither of us
I had never done any woodworking or
anything yeah we didn't have any tools
no tools lived no tools we lived in an
apartment we had no place to work in our
apartment we actually had a little
balcony like a two foot by four foot
balcony I'm exaggerating it was probably
bigger than two okay okay so five feet
yeah okay a three by five balcony other
than this desk what what do people think
that you're gonna do with that balcony I
don't know I think like you put a grill
on it like a tiny tiny grill wait
sometimes that's not allowed I don't
know I don't know I don't even fit two
folding chairs no no not comfortably I
don't really know what they are having
oh you have a balcony yeah that means we
gonna pay charge you a lot more cuz you
have a balcony yeah anyways I'm getting
distracted but that was our very first
project but then we kind of got carried
away with wedding projects the wedding
was like the impetus behind like a lot
of our tool purchases a lot of the very
first projects that we did and I do
think that is a a scenario that does
save you a lot of money because weddings
are so freakin expensive everything is
an upcharge so it made a lot of sense
for us because everything there's
one-off everything is custom and one
often custom that have you heard of
wedding tax wedding tax oh yeah because
it's a wedding they charge you more yeah
so it's like if you're bit if you're
buying a cake if it's for a wedding is
more expensive than if it's just for
yeah if you say it's rumors nay or if
you're renting or if you're getting
flowers say they're for like a
retirement party hmm yeah yeah yeah
don't say it's fair wedding oh that's a
nice flight ACK is that a life hack I
don't know I was trying to say life
protip at the same time you said life
hack and I said think I said life ticket
at the end of life anyway anyways but
you know you know we did the love
letters we did the backdrop we made a
chandelier which we like completely
failed at some point well link below in
the description to some of these
projects well we have a whole podcast
about DIY fails so oh yeah we going to
more detail on them yeah I think like
but I like the way the way we started
out on this path is to save money and
and that continued into our house when
we when we bought the house the very
first thing that we did like in terms of
getting our hands like dirty with a
house is we decided that we needed to
fix a leak in the attic and we decided
that we're gonna take on a whole
plumbing project ourselves and replace a
leaky run of yeah not a galvanized
galvanized pipe yeah we decided that we
were gonna replace galvanized pipe in
the Attic yeah I don't know why we
thought we could do that yeah I get it
we did it
again I don't want to go into too much
detail because we talked about all of
this in the DIY fails podcast but maybe
we'll get into some of the like how we
recommend people should start yeah okay
yeah oh yeah yeah that's why I wrote
these down I think that you should start
by looking at the project and by tools
around that accomplish a goal because
then immediately those tools will have
been worth it instead of buying tools
and then thinking oh now that I have
once I have the tools then the projects
will come I think start with a project
and then the tools will be worth it
right away yeah and I think also then
you avoid the trap of not trap but you
avoid the mistake of buying tools that
you're you never use um like for example
and and like Oh
it's misleading because you might buy
something for a future project that you
might have in mind down the line but
really try to stick to buying for what
you need for the thing you're gonna
tackle next
for example we when we first bought our
house we got one of those like 10% off
before they sponsored us we weren't even
making content then and we went to the
store and got everything that we thought
we might need like what else are we
gonna get a 10% off everything not even
that much no I know I know like we have
a sledgehammer
I wanted that sledgehammer I just I'm
still glad we have it we got it because
we were like we're gonna like break off
the back Patti break up the back patio
and install a new pair you know what I
hit it once I broke off a chunk of it
you did you broke off the corner just
for fun because you couldn't help
yourself and then we never use that
sledgehammer again hey could come in
handy the zombie apocalypse you know
it'd be great that never needs
sharpening it never needs we actually
get we actually did when Harvey hit oh
yeah that's that that's for real real
there is um a lot of like if you're in a
one-story house you don't have it so
Harvey was the flied the big flood that
hit Texas a couple couple years ago and
if you didn't have a second-story in
your house you only had one story you
know they're warning people not to go
into the Attic because people were
getting trapped in the attics yeah
because you can't exit the Attic there's
no the Attic so if it keeps on floating
up and up and up you can get trapped in
there yeah so we had like a hatchet and
a sledgehammer we gave one of them to
our neighbor yes they didn't have
anything and we're like if we have to go
into the Attic we can chop through our
roof yeah yeah that's that seriously we
we have it it didn't make me feel
slightly better and now I'm like back to
not wanting it anymore in the seventh
yeah I think so you know yeah I guess
like yeah don't buy things for a future
need buy things for a current need and
also one one extra benefit that buying
for then
now bring this is it's also the
motivation you need to do the project
like yeah like cuz if you need something
right now you're gonna do it or if
you're excited about something you're
gonna do it yeah and and if you buy
stuff for future projects that you're
not really ready to tackle by the time
you get to tackling them it's like
sometimes you might change your mind
about what you need yeah
or you might be less motivated to tackle
them because you you bought all the
stuff and chose everything a long time
ago and you know you might do but I
don't want to like totally get out of
the the question of what should you buy
to get started by just avoiding it I'll
say these are the most general tools
that will be good for almost everything
things that we used in almost every
single project getting a good drill
slash driver and having like multiple
modes so that can go slow when you're
driving and fast when you're drilling I
think that's a good investment right
there you jot it down a few things I
jotted down a few things I'm gonna try
to guess a few more of them okay okay
circular saw I I went back and forth
between circulars on jigsaw what do you
think
I think circular saw you think circular
because I think I think so for us we got
a jigsaw first that was our choice
because the first project was the
marquee letters I'm cutting out yeah we
needed a curve for an O we were getting
into tight corners and yeah an E and a V
and you know different letters and
that's what worked for us but I think
most projects you're just doing straight
cuts yeah you're not cutting around
something intricate like a letter and so
I think a circular saw is more versatile
it's more breaking it can also do you
know you can do rips you can do yes cuts
yep so you know you can do both of those
on a jigsaw so it's getting the cutting
it straight like yeah you can you can if
you're patient but it's also not as
powerful of a tool yeah I don't know arm
ours is pretty powerful I guess so I
just yeah
you can go pretty fast if you go you
couldn't make yourself like a guide yeah
good yeah circular saw like like
depending on the project get a circular
saw or a jigsaw circular saw is like a
higher quality tools I think if you're
gonna get a jigsaw you got to get like a
nicer one yeah you gotta get a nicer way
yeah yeah yeah if you want to actually
be able like if you're gonna cut down a
sheet of plywood with a jigsaw where's
the sounds ridiculous but you gotta get
like a really good really good one you
can get by with a cheaper circular saw
yeah I agree
how do you at that and I think besides
those two I don't think that there's too
many like general purpose tools that
everybody needs I think there's other
stuff that you're gonna need for every
project that's not really it's not like
a power tool but like lamps clamps yeah
clamp sort of a good general thing we
use clamps a lot yeah again you can just
start by getting ones you need for that
project but they are kind of a general
thing that I think you will use I think
that one good tool for like intro making
now this only really applies if you're
making like furniture or things like
that but I think a pocket whole kit is a
great like booster to have yeah it gets
you like but if you have a drill driver
a jig circular saw and a pocket hole kit
you can build you you can build most
things as those three tools not only
furniture but also like things for your
house like built-ins yeah you know
things like that
yeah with with those three tools you can
build a ridiculous amount of stuff and
I'm mainly thinking of woodworking
because we're working is like a great
entry level making started with making
or probably if they're like asking what
tools to buy it's primarily woodworking
tools is probably not metalworking yeah
metalworking that's like a whole nother
level of commitment yeah yeah we're we
are I mean we're not pros on anything
but we're even less knowledgeable about
metalworking yeah but I think that
another thing I mean you know for our
YouTube channel we like building stuff
because the transformation like you you
want the transformation to be very
visible but I think that there's a lot
that you can accomplish too with just
like a spray paint
or paint brushes and paint yeah or like
lots of other little things like that
that's a great way like you know that's
that's still making it's interesting
because like around the time we started
making stuff for the wedding and making
stuff for the house and maybe I've
touched on this before I know it's a
thought I've had before but all the DIY
blogs and a lot of the DIY channels
we're doing more basic stuff like that
like more beginner level stuff like find
a a thrifted table yeah you maybe swap
out the top spray paint the legs and you
have a new table yeah yeah and it was
more it was a lot more like upcycling
and things with more limited tools but I
think also it's like when we were
getting into that I was kind of right
around the recession so maybe like
thrifty ideas world oh yeah extra
appealing to people yeah no totally so
yeah so those would be like some basic
tools to start with and again I think
like clamps I see I cheated I looked at
your list accidentally getting some
basic safety yeah that's super important
to get like protection for your eyes and
your ears right away get some breathing
protection if you're gonna be cutting
and like you you think oh well I'm just
doing one thing I don't really need
breathing protection for this or I
production you always need it I know
that we're not the best thing yeah do we
say no yeah yeah you know you know
always always use protection moving on
so I think that uh there's a few like
common excuses that I'm not sure of
excuses it the best word like common
reasons why people don't make or think
they can't make or reasons they're not
making it like so some of the things we
touched on earlier you know about our
situation yeah yeah we fit a lot of
common excuses yeah so one common excuse
is I don't have enough space we touched
on this a little bit earlier we just
started on our balcony but what if you
don't have a balcony or what if your
house is already completely full what
other opportunities might you have I
think taking things outside there's
always an option and I know it's a
little bit more back and forth but
there's a lot of open space outside you
can also
it really good and like dexter kill room
it you know oh yeah like you can hang
sheets in section off a certain area of
your I know like Ben Ben who's done that
before yeah yeah I've seen other people
do it too so it's a little again it's a
little bit more of a pain but you can
totally do it yeah or if you're living
in a bigger city that might have a
makerspace you can like rent out a
little cubicle there and then that's
like your maker zone and you can use
their tools and that's a good way to get
around a lot of a different excuses yeah
that's also a chance to try out tools if
you want to try something before you buy
it or if there's a tool where you need
it for a project but maybe it's a really
specific thing that you can't foresee
meeting again mm-hmm you know and maybe
you can't justify buying it just for
that one use you can go to a makerspace
yep yep don't have enough time that's
when we hear a lot too and I think that
one thing we have kind of realized as we
have spent more and more and more of our
time doing that this business is I think
we've kind of reshift it to like
realizing that when people say they
don't have enough time it's it's not a
high enough priority because you can
always make time but it's just is it a
big enough priority and you know if
you're if the excuse you run into is you
don't have enough time then maybe
realizing that it's not a big enough
priority and alike stop putting pressure
on yourself
and you'll get to it when you get to it
damn I that might help you out some yeah
or and also you know thinking about it
as a matter of priority not a matter of
time you can look at the things you're
spending your time on and see if maybe
one of those things you're just doing
out of habit and it's not as high of a
priority you know scary when you install
that time tracker app on your phone that
tracks how much time you spend in each
app and then you realize how much time
you spend on Reddit in the past yeah it
adds up it adds up you think oh just
like I you've guessed
oh I spend maybe twenty minutes on
Reddit a week No
with certain things like like Rhetta on
your phone there's difference between
like you know doing a few five-minute
sessions a day every day and that adds
up to I don't know a big enough chunk of
time to have done a project but ya
couldn't necessarily have it might not
have made sense to shadow work in that
project and each of those little
five-minute yeah it's like if you're
building a table you can't just like go
this off
really this is make sense to go out
measure one length and then go back to
what you're doing but I do think there
are some things like if you you know and
there's other ways to like track what
you're doing not just apps on your phone
but you know you might realize oh I'm
going to the grocery store four times a
week because I'm not great at meal
planning and so then you say okay if I
change things around and I plan it so
that I don't have to go to the grocery
store one time a week that's a big chunk
of time all those trips back and forth
that I could put toys you know I could
have a couple hours towards making a
thing yeah so I think looking at it as a
matter of priority and know that if it
is high enough priority can fit it and
if there's literally nothing from your
life that you can move right now then
that means you're focusing on the things
that are a higher priority and maybe in
the future making stuff will be more of
a priority yeah you know one one kind of
excuse that I think that you should
definitely touch on I know you just did
that talking segment but my voice is
still like Republic yeah I haven't
finished planning it yet or it's not
perfect yet cuz I think that's something
that you struggle with a lot yes well
and it's kind of ironic because like I
so when it comes to planning our
projects I think I plan more of the
aesthetic stuff and you plan more of the
how it's going to functionally go
together yeah you know and so it's
interesting because like a lot of the
planning is on you but I feel like I'm
the one that is always holding on
holding a thought when it comes to the
planning yeah I think that if you were
in charge of like the whole thing we'd
have a hard time starting but I think
since I'm in charge of like the putting
it together I just like start us
you're along the ride and the way you
just kind of have to like start because
I'm starting yeah yeah I know that's
true but like in the pre-planning phase
and I'm trying to get everything perfect
so some things I've done and this is
just me because I am a very visual
person I use Photoshop and illustrator
and sketching a lot to plan stuff
because I need to see proportions I need
to see colors and that makes me be able
to make decisions faster than I would
otherwise I know I'm still really slow
imagine how much slower it would be if I
was just imagining things in my brain
but like for example our our front door
makeover or our closet door makeover or
even this desk you know that was a
render not a Photoshop or a laundry room
so many different projects I would
Photoshop the so for the door the color
of the front door the different sconces
I even photoshopped in like the hardware
little things like that and being able
to see it help would help me make a
quicker decision like oh I like that
style of lights but not with our style
of house that actually doesn't look good
okay I'll swap it I think it's ironic
too because I asked you how do you like
just the start and pull the trigger and
get going on a project and you're like
well you plan more this is the way the
photoshopping trick is a way for me to
make the decision making faster I still
think I'm I don't think it's necessarily
good advice to say don't plan I know I
know and like all of the project he
talked about were made a lot better
because all of the planning that we did
I guess like how do you know when it's
right to just pull the trigger because
what if you get stuck in a loop of like
I cuz because I think the reason why we
go sometimes is I'm kind of sitting
there going ah okay I was like alright
we'll go we'll go like what if what have
you got stuck in a loop of just
continually planning like what if you
wanted to keep on finding that perfect
light or sconce or like with the desk
the desk would have been a really really
really hard thing for you because Calvin
wants to make it minimal
and clean but there's a lot of stuff we
need to fit into here I think you would
have gone on loops for a long time so I
think what I've done to make myself pull
the trigger even when I do want to keep
going in loops again is I try to remind
myself like okay I'm the reason we're
doing this project is you know either we
don't have a thing and we need a thing
or we have it you know some old solution
that isn't a solution anymore and we
need something better or we have this
blank space and we want to put art there
and the thing I do try to remind myself
is like whatever we do is gonna be
better than it was yeah you know and you
know I might be getting hung up on the
angle of the side pieces of the legs on
this desk but then I remind myself like
our old desk key a table with a piece of
wood and clamped to it different yeah
and so I think I think that's a good
thing to keep in mind when you're
tackling these projects yeah
yeah I definitely helped me with the
door cuz I was like yeah no matter what
happens it's gonna be better than what
it was yeah yeah
and I think also reminding yourself that
sometimes the little things that you get
hung up on that's not what people are
gonna see mmm people are gonna see the
bigger picture yeah you know what about
like when people worry that their idea
isn't original enough like I think that
that's something that we've struggled
with you know well like well for us in
particular since we're making content
it's doubly important I feel for us to
feel like we're actually contributing
something yeah but you know I think that
that uh especially when you're starting
out you know what also Benson like what
your goals are for making it you know if
if you are just wanting to make a piece
of furniture to fulfill a need there's
no need for it to be original just go
with what already works yeah oh yeah I
mean I think if you're just making stuff
for yourself
doesn't matter if it's original at all
like if you see a table you like and you
want that table in your house you just
make that exact table it's maker yeah
yeah it is harder when you're doing
content creation and
wanna put your own spin on things or if
you're selling stuff you know you can't
copy what someone else is doing yeah
but also even like copying something
like things might get messed up it might
end up a little bit different and you're
gonna you might end up with something
unique or if you're copying something is
probably because you're not familiar
enough with the thing that you're making
to fully understand it and come up with
your own ideas
so copying someone else's work you know
credit them of course but copying
someone else's design that's a great way
to learn that's a great way to build up
confidence and then the next one that
you make might be more unique yeah
that's very true yeah cuz sometimes it's
it's hard to come up with a unique
design and a plan of how to make the
thing if you are just getting started
and you haven't come up with designs
before and you haven't come up with
plans to make the things or made things
at all so when you're if you can
eliminate some of those barriers and say
like okay well I don't need to come up
with the design or the how you know
steps to go through because I saw this
person do it on YouTube
so I'm gonna use their design I'm gonna
use their steps and I'll just get more
familiar with the tools mm-hmm you know
yeah so I think that's definitely a good
point in the beginning take less
pressure on yourself yeah take less put
less pressure yeah yeah I got it I got
it yeah all right what about the excuse
of I don't know how Oh YouTube yeah you
do anything on YouTube but it is
surprising continually to see like how
much people are capable of that they
don't know I mean we are at spring make
of the other day and I saw crafts with
Ellen making a amazing metal and wood
stool and like you know she does like
some really awesome sewing projects and
things like that but I think this was
her first woodworking yeah I just like
thought that she was like you know she
had done woodworking before and she just
hadn't shown around her social media and
she just knocked out this amazing design
her first try and I'm like that is
ghosts it's like you know one she's
pretty badass but also it just shows you
that you're capable of more than you
might think if you just put yourself out
there
and put yourself in a situation where
you kind of have to make it work yeah
you know I will say like like some tools
are scarier than others some tools are
scarier than others like I still like
tables I still make me nervous yeah you
know for dangerous tools often times in
mine I think it really really helps to
be with someone who understands it yeah
use it with them and and get kind of
like some guidance from them so you know
again a local makerspace might be great
or if you have like a friend or friend
or family member that understands that
yeah
reach out learn learn from people who
have that experience and once you've
seen them do it and you know they have
coached you through it and in person it
helps so much there's also things like
you know you if you're getting wood at
like Lowe's or Home Depot or like a
hardware store they can cut things down
for you yeah you know so you can
eliminate some of that you know some of
that tool usage yeah then you can change
your design to simplify it enough so
that you don't have to do much to it
that's true we still do that like if you
can if we're designing something we're
gonna design it using dimensional lumber
that we don't have to do any rips on
like it's gonna be 11 and a half inches
wide cuz that's what a one by twelve is
yeah you know I know that's we designed
our entire entryway table around
dimensional dimensional lumber you know
and like Chris is ironic because then we
ended up getting walnut that's still had
to be ripped down but still but still
but still I mean the design intent was
there yeah and I think that one thing
that Chris alimony from four-eyes
furniture says a lot is measurements
aren't as important as consistency so if
you if you make both legs the same
length like you cut them at the same
time then you don't need to worry about
accuracy as much yeah because they're
the same and it's gonna be level yeah
doesn't matter if they're twenty seven
and a quarter tall versus twenty seven
and an eight tall if they're both the
same yeah so so those are some good good
tricks to kind of like hack the system
yes we're so Haxorus right now
man I look so much taller than you
sometimes which is weird because our
chairs are at the same height and
vouching yeah I know sorry for people
listening there I go there look a proper
you look I'm so proper
all right one other common excuses do
you think people have and how can we
help them so one is losing steam on a
project whether have you ever done that
um well we've abandoned a couple
projects but more because we didn't
think they make good videos yeah
actually I can really only think of like
one but more because that we didn't
think they make good videos not because
like we couldn't do the project yeah um
but I mean if someone listening is
wanting to content too and that's so
thank you remind ya but ya losing steam
on a project sometimes it happens cuz
you hit a wall and there's like some
kind of snag that you can't figure out
how to solve it
sometimes it's cuz it's just taking too
long and you're losing enthusiasm you
know what one thing that actually helps
a ton with this having a social media
presence and like putting out there that
you're doing something and then the
community kind of holds you a little bit
accountable because they want to see how
it turns out yeah well and also it's
great because if you hit a snag you can
reach out to the community like we we're
getting so many snags with smooth-on oh
yeah yeah oh with the coasters yeah what
the coasters and we reached up you know
on instagram with some stories and we
got so many suggestions yeah and it was
so much better after that yeah but like
it's it's a great resource and it holds
you accountable
um I think also if you're hitting a wall
because things are taking more time than
you then you expect it I think it's easy
to look at YouTube and everything is
sped up you know 10 times 3 and all the
like fat is trimmed from the video and
you're just seeing the cuts but you mean
you're not seeing all the time it took
to set up and measure you know the hour
of measuring all your stuff before you
even started cutting yeah and I know
that like some people also might find it
frustrating that they watch a video and
it's perfect and everything works great
and then they try it and it doesn't work
at all yeah and that might be due to a
lot of things it could be because the
person that you're watching has done it
300 times
they're very experienced at it and they
know all the nuances and you don't yeah
they made a mistake and cut it out yeah
yeah yeah which is also very common we
know it happens yeah yeah well I think
that's one reason why we try to include
our mistakes but even us like there's
some some mistakes that we don't include
you know so even even the people that
show their mistakes and I feel like we
at least have one major mistake often
more than that in every video but
sometimes even us we'll cut something
little because it's like oh well we
measured a thing wrong and maybe it was
entertaining the first time that we
measured something wrong again and it's
not entertaining to show it the second
time or yeah or whatever so like even
even our channel doesn't show all like
every single mistake it's coz when it
like when it messes up the flow it's
more for like the sake of the video flow
than anything else I would say it's it's
part for the sake of the video flow oh
you mean eliminating it eliminating it
yeah yeah yeah I mean if we weren't
worried about the flow of the video we
just include all of it but and
oftentimes we'll talk about it like in
the after shows yeah yeah but just know
that everyone is making mistakes all the
time yeah I think that when I was
younger I always assumed that adults
knew what they were doing and then when
I when I realized that I'm an adult now
and I'm oh no one knows what they're
doing
yeah it's kind of freeing and worrying
at the same time yeah you know yeah and
I think that's it after all of that you
have no more excuses so you should start
making if you want to and if you don't
want to then that's totally fine also
alright you know time it is Kailen game
time
that's a great dance right there that
Celine's of our song oh wow I know it in
my head I don't you edit the podcast I
have a horrible memory let me pull up my
document yeah okay so guys Caitlyn has
challenged me to my knowledge of
Pinterest after all of you guys know
what Pinterest is but what you guys
might not know is they put out like
quarterly and yearly guides about
content and trends and all sorts of
different things did the research put
out every year a Pinterest Trends list
based on what was searched on Pinterest
and and I know that because I've heard
about it on the young house love
podcasts yes young house love we've
mentioned their podcast before they do
occasional gaming segments and they did
a similar one where they compared
current year trends to last year trends
yeah so I'm gonna do something similar
with you because I think this is gonna
be funny it's not I didn't structure it
to where it's always current you're okay
but you just have to guess which there's
gonna be different categories I'm gonna
tell you two trends okay and then you
have to guess which is a true trend in
which trend I made up well what if what
if I'm a trendsetter and the community
just hasn't realized that the trend I
chose is correct
well okay you're gonna have to not look
at my list okay I will look at the
camera at the camera I love like I was
gonna look off into the distance but you
guys are right here so I'm gonna look at
you if my eyes glanced away you'll know
I'm cheating yeah you can call him out
on it that's creepy
please don't stare at them okay you
ready
ready okay I'm gonna start with the
hobbies category all right so this is um
yeah well it's hobbies that's pretty
pretty broad but some of it is kind of
related to some stuff we do so
do you think was a trending search early
retirement or hustles at home side
hustles oh come on in happy hustles
because of all the hashtag hustle
hashtag hustle life the hustle still
real when was it trending oh it was
trending a little bit earlier but
retirement life no early retirement Oh
early retirement Oh early retirement
everyone wants to retire early and
everyone wants a side hustle but I think
it was like well hustling can be a hobby
when you're still hustling yeah you know
and I guess like the things you do it's
kind of related cuz planning for early
retirement is like some yeah but it's a
lot of the same things that people do
for side hustles yeah oh I'm gonna flip
houses yeah early retirement first side
for the versed hustle life I'm gonna say
hustle life yeah that's it yeah you
tried to throw me off I almost flipped
at that moment I almost flipped because
I feel like it was like maybe we just
saw this more cuz 2017 is when we
started our channel in 2016 was when we
were doing the products I thought it was
more around them when it was like oh
hashtag boss babe yeah hashtag hustle
life hashtag like coffee and repeat you
know coffee coffee hashtag hashtag like
mosh come out of my mouth coffee
so hustles at home that search term yes
very specific was up six hundred ninety
percent ninety percent that's a lot of
percentage is that crazy that's crazy
yeah so it's like a lot of people and
you know I always feel like we're kind
of biased because we're like yeah I'd do
a side hustle cause like you know we
have we had a side hustle it turned into
a main hustle and then side hustles on
top of the side hustle yeah like we're
always telling people oh yeah you should
totally do that yes it's interesting
that it actually is like people are
searching for it more and wanting that
more that's really interesting
okay another which of these search terms
was trending acrylic poor painting ooh
or soap making okay
soap-making I feel like I don't know I
feel like the more trending thing is
like soap like when they destroy soap
with knives
do you like the ASMR type stuff that's
more trendy but people wouldn't search
for that on Pinterest yeah Pinterest you
search for inspiration and like how to's
okay well as other one besides soap
acrylic pour paint acrylic board you
know acrylic porous so hot right now
so hot I mean so hot I I'm leaning
towards acrylic pores just cuz I'm
biased towards acrylic force cuz it cool
whereas they're awesome cutting yeah
yeah at first I was gonna write slime
and I was like no slime is so 2018 it's
so 20th 2017 so 2017 I was like what's
the new thing soap cutting mm-hmm yeah
I'm not good at this you're trying to
continually throw me off I know I am but
I told you you thought you'd be better
than you expected so I'm still right
even though you're winning you are so
right yeah search terms for acrylic pour
painting up six hundred sixty percent
Wow
we should do more acrylic poor paintings
I know I like let's do it yeah okay
let's do it okay okay the next this is
the next one still in the hobbies
category camper remodel or boat building
Oh camper remodel is so trendy right now
it's so hot right now I wanna make that
joke every single time I am sorry I am
sorry boat making boat building or
camper remodel I think camper remodel
you're wrong what no I know right boat
okay so I will say camper remodel was
trending in 2018 Oh No nine hundred
thirty three percent up an eight twenty
eighteen yeah but this year boat
building what has seen an increase of
one hundred sixty nine percent whoa
in third chance yeah that's what
building yeah I know some people who
build boats know what we do have play
to make a boat we do we do yes it's a
silly boat we do every time we always
forget we even have a partner though
that would be a great mishmash
gorilla oh okay yeah we're doing that
we're doing it guys make sure we do our
boat project even we even wanted to do
this it's a competition - I'm gonna make
a boat and you're gonna make a boat
because I have different ideas about
boat building yeah as opposed to you
yeah okay okay yep that NC we're on
trend everyone's all see our video okay
we're gonna go to a new category now all
right travel mmm okay so which travel
term has been searched more in 29 - I
hustle life that's not a travel term
desert escapes or abandoned castles who
abandoned castles like classic I think
so right castles everyone's kind of
interested in castles I feel like people
like things like like famous landmark
castles Oh abandoned castles that's very
particular yeah what's other one so
abandoned castles and desert escapes
desert escapes I think is the winner
ding ding nope you got me so it was one
in 2018 I'm a year behind trend yeah it
was 125 percent but I feel like that's
still kind of trendy I feel like you're
still seeing a lot of people doing
desert sensitive beaches yeah you know
like Camelback photos yeah but yeah
abandoned castles which is interesting
like and so it goes into more details
for things so this one was called game
of stones and seeking out dilapidated
castles oh because of the Game of
Thrones trend maybe I don't know I think
they were just trying to make a pun but
it's in sort like like literally
abandoned castle
yeah that's interesting yeah not famous
how many abandoned castles are there
cool I would love I'd like to explore
abandoned castle at night that's yes yes
I would with no one well I was gonna say
with no one else I mean over you of
course not like with the tour no no no
no no no guided I just want to trespass
yeah and you know be extra good extra
football points if there is an abandoned
like graveyard there too there probably
would be bodies buried healing scent
like a little creepy person okay
so there was in college there is an
insane asylum do you know about the
insane is the abandoned one yeah there's
like a there's a person that lives there
and shoots people oh really
I had some friends that went and I was
so what said that I didn't go I didn't
know they were going oh man it was like
it wasn't like a planned thing it was
like a spur of the moment and I was so
sad because I really wanted to go but of
course like the rule follower in me was
not really comfortable with trespassing
oh so I probably wouldn't have done it
even if I had known haha like I want to
deep inside yes I do I just want to do
like ghost hunting I just love all those
like ghost hunters let's do some time
let's do it get my little like EVP me
yeah yeah yeah yeah evident Kalyn try go
something like evident gonna try to make
contact with ghosts it's still making so
make making we can make yeah okay you
gonna be oh no III I came up with an
idea of something to prank us but I'm
not gonna say tell me it's just like the
prank well these everyone listening
hasn't seen that video I won't mention
it I haven't tries to prank me in the
next day get excited get excited I'm a
prankster prankster
i'ma loose okay I'm gonna do the axon so
again this is in the Travel category
which search term is trending in 2019
surprise destination or 24
or travel 24-hour travel is probably
just like quick trips like you like go
there and pop back um
I'm leaning towards 24-hour travel just
because with all the hashtag hustle and
busy life and like everyone glorifying
being busy all the time like 24 hour
travel sounds like on trend or maybe a
see year old I don't know it's it
totally makes sense
I actually don't really get it's a
surprise destination
okay surprise destination does that mean
that like someone else plans a trip for
you and you just show up there sort of
so it's like with a group okay you tell
everyone to clear their calendars and
one person plans it and everyone else
just shows up that sounds like it could
go well or could go bad like you need
like well what what what what what type
of things do I wear what do I need to
prepare for do I need like to get scuba
certified before I go there like so I
like pack my scuba cart many layers do I
need layers do yeah there's a lot of
things yeah I feel like you it may be
you have to pick like a category of trip
yeah we're going to a beach and it's
gonna be hot so prepare for that and
then you could to suppress that work
which Beach yeah responsibility does
that person get their trip paid for by
the rest of the group for doing the
planning for them because good volume
the same time what if what if it sucks
then everyone's upset at that one person
and friendship is ruined
yeah you know that'd be better doing the
24 hour travel trip surprise destination
then it's not that much of a like
commitment you know combine the two yes
we'll see you that so surprise
destination that was only at 192 percent
yeah okay new category health and
wellness mmm okay so the the search term
is it ginger oil or macadamia milk I
don't even know what macadamia milk is I
mean it's milk from macadamia not I
guess you know but also the whole thing
like milk from nuts still concerns me
because it's called milk yeah it's like
couldn't they call like thickened I here
now and moving on so it's not the nuts I
just had to move away from the nuts
what's the other one
ginger oil or macadamia this ginger oil
because we just gotta get away from
those not yeah I knew it I knew it deep
down in my nuts now that I have a
podcast my macadamia nuts I have them
right here they just off-screen percent
what does enjoy will do I don't know why
no ginger is like good for your stomach
yeah I'll give you a stomach issue just
like the ginger like root and will I
like the oil extracted out I guess I
didn't think it had oil in it maybe it's
like oil infused with ginger I don't
know I don't really know it doesn't say
it just says people are embracing their
inner ginge and using the soothing oil'
for baths massages and even condiments I
already hear the word ginge I hate it
why would he do that
yeah like ginger ginger tea also I made
up macadamia milk I just picked another
night that I heard the milk before you
could have gone with any of them but you
had to go with macadamia you know I want
it I couldn't do like almond milk that's
boring now oh it needs to be something
like you know resurgence no no you need
a new exciting that milk macadamia
macadamia it is alright from Hawaii oh
yeah
fancy fancy okay um another one which of
these terms is trending Jazzercise or
banned workouts the hand workouts
a flexible band okay I was like like
it's like a marching band like you just
go March and the Sun with a big heavy
tuba and that's the workouts or
Jazzercise
I think bands aren't the answer because
that's more for physical therapy and
stuff and I just haven't seen that the
Jazzercise is like something that I
could see making a resurgence because
Jazzercise was popular like way back
when you know and like stuff like that
that's been so far removed coming back
in you know what what does that dance
competition that YouTube video I showed
you oh it was it was like the Crystal
Light like aerobics dance yeah there was
like an aerobics dance or something so
light sponsored aerobics all I think
it's a Jazzercise you're wrong what yeah
what I threw that in there because I
knew that would be your logic especially
after we watch the Crystal Light aerobic
dancing yes yeah but banned workouts
1913 percent what yeah I used to work
out with bands always before my time
yeah yeah cuz I injured my shoulder and
I needed to do physical therapy really
because it's like an indoor exercise
learning your exercises are what you can
do it in your office here's this close
close your office door I mean you could
do Jazzercise in your office too well
with your bluetooth headphones yeah yeah
but I would like to see the resurgence
of Jazzercise we should do it we should
do our own Jazzercise visit video I'm
gonna Kaitlin make excuse for everything
we have the word making there guys yeah
that would be fun alright alright let's
do it okay but not really okay so the
next one is parties only didn't work for
this category um
versus party animals we only need one
that's party animals it's kind of like
party / event kind of celebration tape
yes
one is godparent proposals one the other
is new pet gender reveals what
I don't like either of those they both
seem a little bit extra extra I think
okay this is a dog the dog a gender or
the pet gender-reveal seems like quite
extra but like the the godparent
proposal thing just seems like you're
taking something that should be genuine
and making it into something that like I
know you could not that proposals are in
genuine it just seems like it's like the
promposal taking over further yeah yeah
it's like it's like spreading up
something unnecessary it's like it
should just be like a genuine
conversation you have not like a big
thing like a Flashdance yes a Flashdance
proposal to be a god parent something I
don't know I think I think that the
thing that that's more likely is the dog
there's a pet thing the pet
gender-reveal nope what godparent
proposals what's going on they're up 152
percent the new pet gender reveals that
actually is the thing I heard of I was
listen to some podcast and someone had
done a they had like adopted a puppy or
something and a lot of their friends and
family had been asking about the dog and
this and that and so to introduce the
dog to their new friends and family they
have like a fake gender reveal party Oh
for the dog but then apparently they got
a ton of hate on Facebook Oh reddit
reddit sweat it works oh yeah they got a
ton of hate on Facebook because they
were like if you're doing a gender
reveal for your dog then you're like
only acknowledging binary genders Oh
which I mean it's kind of like it's a
gender reveal for a dog like it's
obviously like a silly thing everyone in
the comments was like yeah people are
just getting upset just to be upset it's
like maybe gender reveals as a whole is
something that you know could be
rethought yeah but like if someone's
doing like a joking gender reveal for
their dog it's like okay there's no
one's no one's trying to hurt anything
okay so also I'm going back on my
initial impressions of both you know
what
do what makes you happy that's the most
important do what makes me happy be
considerate of others and that's all we
need to worry about you love your dog if
you want to have a flash dance to
propose your godparents yeah go for it
do you know what I think I think that
people finding joy in life is beautiful
no matter what maybe it's just maybe
it's a good thing that there's more and
more possibly seemingly silly
celebrations yeah about things that
people didn't make big deals about
before but it's like we're kind of like
having like oh well Wednesday's our date
nights yeah and so now Wednesdays are
fun yeah or like it makes the like event
last longer in your memory because it's
a bigger thing you're making you're
taking time to acknowledge someone or
something I still wouldn't have expected
godparent proposals though that when I
was like so um how much time do we have
sorry I can just do a couple more and
save there a couple more yeah yeah this
is fun there's a good game so I'll do
I'll do a couple home ones okay okay so
which was a more more of a search term
upscale vinyl tiles or painted floor
tiles upscale vinyl tiles is my initial
like gut response only because I've seen
them with like renovations of RVs really
yeah like for like budget makeovers mmm
or painted at tile painted painted floor
tiles that seems like a bad idea
I don't know paint never ends up perfect
and four floors you'd want them to be
pretty good right
I think vinyl you're wrong oh gosh I'm
so bad at this I started off so strong
painted floor tiles by 1276 Wilson oh
you mean like professionally painted no
no no I like paying your own tiles like
paint your own tiles so yeah don't
here's that here's the
description no paint no gain don't tear
up that tile people are painting their
parquet floors with bold colors and
mosaic patterns so they're painting
wooden tile floors okay is wood right
parquet is wood but it's painted floor
tiles I think they're just using that as
an example hmm there are paints that are
meant for tiles I've seen them used more
in like backsplashes like if you have a
like if you're somewhere where the tiles
in good shape but maybe it's like a 50s
you know baby pink bathroom yeah
I've seen where people will paint it
white and those tiles meant for paint
meant for tile like super high-gloss
yeah it's like hardcore it the same way
like I think there's even paint for
redoing like a bathtub oh I don't know
if it's the same kind of stuff because
that that it has to be seems like a big
pain in the butt a big paint in the butt
no game yeah I thought it was
interesting that is interesting because
that would be a huge thing in the same
way like painting your walls makes such
a big difference in a room if you could
paint your floors yeah or just paint
like your backsplash or whatever that
could be a huge difference it's so much
cheaper it's so much easier so paint
like a path from your bed to your
bathroom and glow-in-the-dark paint so
you never have to turn on your phone
just have a guided path you know what we
were doing research for the Ethernet
installation like infomercial at the
beginning we were looking at a bunch of
info and one I was like okay okay okay
yeah it's these slippers that you put on
and when it registers you're like when
it senses your weight in the slippers
there's a tiny little light at the toe
of each slipper that lights your way and
I was like okay that's kind of genius
yeah pretty good until it breaks well
yeah and then until you have to clean it
clean clean your slippers you just wear
your slippers forever and never clean
them like put them in the wash oh you're
oh well maybe you can take the light out
probably yeah
still I think it's opening it up to
failure points but still I mean like
like having those as your like nighttime
slippers for your like going to the walk
into the restroom yeah you shouldn't
wear them during the day yeah time you
saw me yeah
nighttime you certainly okay is this a
good place to end it or should we get
one more will say because I'm about
halfway through what I prepared no I'll
save the rest for another time if you
guys like this game I thought it was
great fun I am pretty excited to play it
again yeah all right let's uh let's go
back to our is it time for our thing of
the week it's time for the thing of the
week
all right my thing of the week is our
gaming channel in particular totally
accurate battle simulator
it's the latest video we've published
over there it's so much fun and I just
want to play it again because it's so
accurate it's not really accurate at all
it's like a physics based stimulation of
like battles happening and everything's
very sloppy
everyone has googly eyes it's very
frustrating sometimes because it's you
you can't control it so you just set up
this battle and then say go and you see
what happens but I love it we want to
start recreating like historical battles
or battles from like TV shows or movies
in it yeah and and and that that's it
that's my obsession um my thing of the
week is a silent Mouse here listen wait
let me do it listen do you hear that no
you don't I'm clicking it wait let me
put it to the mic you might barely hear
it there it's so quiet
I don't like but also it's satisfying
it's satisfying to click it still feels
clicky you can feel the click in your
finger you still feel the click but it's
quiet and there's something about it
they're just like feels I don't know
calming I know it's weird to say some
high-end oh you're higher yeah
and it's not that expensive of a mouse
or anything I mean we'll put it we'll
put a link to it than the notes but it's
I don't know it just feels really nice
and it works on like a lot of different
surfaces it's a good Mouse - its
Logitech but it's I don't know what's we
originally got it for our gaming yeah
because we would be clicking and we
didn't want it to pick up the sound of
our clicks but now I have one it might
ask and it's just like really nice like
not you don't really think about it till
you try it but not having that click
constantly in your ear is really nice
yes $18 know about it oh that's not bad
for like a wireless mouse all right guys
wait thank you so much for joining us on
this week's podcast thank you again for
everyone who's left a review on our
Podcast it makes us happy and close on
the inside thank you for subscribing to
the podcast YouTube channel and leave
your comments there it's always fun to
read and people write like a lot yeah
yeah there's some good discussions going
on and make sure to tell your mom about
this podcast specifically just your mom
or your friend for dads dies our next
week
[Music]